.
PLEASE STAND BY.
THE EVENT WILL BEGIN SHORTLY.
YOU
♪
Live from Beverly Hills,
California, please welcome the
President of the Academy of
Motion Picture Arts an
[APPLAUSE]
JANET YANG:  Good morning! And
welcome to the Oscars
nominations announcement. It is
so exciting to be back live,
once again, to kick-off the
official countdown to the 95th
Oscars on March 12th.
[APPLAUSE]
For nearly a century now, the
Oscars has been the most
esteemed celebration of movies
in the world.  It is a chance
for us to showcase the very best
films of the past year, and for
movie fans  to come together as
we shine the spotlight on
artists working on both sides of
the camera.
Every year, nominees in most
categories are chosen by their
peers - actors nominate actors;
film editors
vote for the best edited movies
of the year, and so on. But the
final and most anticipated
award, Best Picture, is chosen
by the entire Academy membership
- that's around 10,000
filmmakers and artists living
and working in over 80
countries.
And now, to present the
nominees,
here are this morning's hosts.
2022 Oscar winner Riz Ahmed and
the star and executive producer
of M3GAN, Allison Williams.
[APPLAUSE]
Good morning, everybody! We've
been awake all night getting
ready for this moment and we're
so excited and honored• an
OVER CAFFEINATED TO REVEAL THE
nominations for the 95th Oscars.
Good morning
Allison, great to be here with
you
*for these
announcements. You've been
Nominated twice and you won an
Oscar last year.  I had a
question-did you get up early
and watch the nominations both
times?
RIZ:
I didn't really wake up because
I couldn't really go to sleep
because of too much
anticipation.
And I know there's a lot of
people who can't wait for us to
get started so without further
ado
Here are the nominees  for
Performance  by an Actress in a
Supporting Role.
RIZ :
ANGELA BASSETT in "Black
Panther: Wakanda Forever"
HONG CHAU in "The Whale"
KERRY CONDON in "The Banshees of
Inisherin"
JAMIE LEE CURTIS in "Everything
Everywhere All at Once"
And
STEPHANIE HSU in "Everything
Everywhere All at Once"
ALLISON:  Next are the nominees
for Achievement in Makeup and
Hairstyling.
"BABYLON"
"BLACK PANTHER: WAKANDA FOREVER"
"ELVIS"
"EVERYTHING EVERYWHERE ALL AT
ONCE"
And
"MRS. HARRIS GOES TO PARIS"
ALLISON:
Riz, given the extraordinary
sound design in your film, Sound
of Metal, why don't you take
this next one?
RIZ:
Got it!
Here are the nominees for
Achievement in Sound.
RIZ:
"ALL QUIET ON THE WESTERN FRONT"
"AVATAR: THE WAY OF WATER"
"THE BATMAN"
"ELVIS"
And
"TOP GUN: MAVERICK"
ALLISON:
Next up, here are the nominees
for Achievement in Music,
Original Score.
ALLISON:
"ALL QUIET ON THE WESTERN FRONT"
"BABYLON"
"THE BANSHEES OF INISHERIN"
"EVERYTHING EVERYWHERE ALL AT
ONCE"
And "THE FABELMANS"
RIZ:
And now, we have the first of
the two award categories
honoring writers.
First is Adapted Screenplay.
The nominees are•
RIZ:
"ALL QUIET ON THE WESTERN FRONT"
- Screenplay by
Edward Berger, Lesley Paterson &
Ian Stokell
"GLASS ONION: A KNIVES OUT
MYSTERY" -
Written by Rian Johnson
"LIVING"- Written by Kazuo
Ishiguro
"TOP GUN: MAVERICK" - Screenplay
by  Ehren Kruger
And Eric Warren Singer and
Christopher McQuarrie
Story by Peter Craig and Justin
Marks
And
"WOMEN TALKING" - Screenplay by
Sarah Polley
ALLISON:
And here are the nominees for
Original Screenplay.
ALLISON:
"THE BANSHEES OF INISHERIN" -
Written by
Martin McDonagh
"EVERYTHING EVERYWHERE ALL AT
ONCE" -
Written by Daniel Kwan & Daniel
Scheinert
"THE FABELMANS" - Written by
Steven Spielberg &
Tony Kushner
"TÁR" -written by Todd Field
And
"TRIANGLE OF SADNESS" - Written
by
Ruben Östlund
RIZ:
It's with great pleasure that I
get to announce this year's
nominees for Best Live Action
Short Film.
RIZ:
"AN IRISH GOODBYE"
"IVALU"
"LE PUPILLE"
"NIGHT RIDE"
And
"THE RED SUITCASE"
RIZ:
Up now, the nominees for Best
Animated
Short Film.
RIZ:
"THE BOY, THE MOLE, THE FOX AND
THE HORSE"
"THE FLYING SAILOR"
"ICE MERCHANTS"
"MY YEAR OF DICKS"
[LAUGHTER]
And
"AN OSTRICH TOLD ME THE WORLD IS
FAKE AND
I THINK I BELIEVE IT"
[APPLAUSE]
ALLISON:
AND NO COMMENT.
Here are the nominees for
Performance by an Actor in a
Supporting Role.
ALLISON:
BRENDAN GLEESON in "The Banshees
of Inisherin"
BRIAN TYREE HENRY in "Causeway"
JUDD HIRSCH in "The Fabelmans"
BARRY KEOGHAN in "The Banshees
of Inisherin"
And
KE HUY QUAN in "Everything
Everywhere All at Once"
ALLISON:
Riz, this is a delight.  I don't
want this to end.  And can I
just say that working with you
is much easier than working with
M3GAN•she's tricky.
RIZ:
She's not around is she?
You promised she wouldn't be
here.
ALLISON:
WE SHOULD BE GOOD.
We'll be right back because in
just a few minutes we've got
more nominee announcements
coming up.
♪
ALLISON:
Welcome back, live from the
Academy's headquarters in
Beverly Hills where Riz and I
are revealing the nominees for
the 95th Oscars.
RIZ:
Earlier we announced 9
categories.  Coming up now are
the final 14, including Best
Picture.
ALLISON:
Here are the nominees for
Achievement in Music, Original
Song.
ALLISON:
"APPLAUSE" from "Tell It like a
Woman"
"HOLD MY HAND" from "Top Gun:
Maverick"
"LIFT ME UP" from "Black
Panther: Wakanda Forever"
"NAATU NAATU" from "RRR"
And
"THIS IS A LIFE" from
"Everything Everywhere All at
Once"
RIZ:
Next up, the nominees for Best
Documentary Feature Film.
RIZ:
"ALL THAT BREATHES"
"ALL THE BEAUTY AND THE
BLOODSHED"
"FIRE OF LOVE"
"A HOUSE MADE OF SPLINTERS"
And
"NAVALNY"
ALLISON:
And here are the nominees for
Best Documentary Short Film.
ALLISON:
"THE ELEPHANT WHISPERERS"
"HAULOUT"
"HOW DO YOU MEASURE A YEAR?"
"THE MARTHA MITCHELL EFFECT"
And
"STRANGER AT THE GATE"
RIZ:
Here are the nominees for Best
International Feature Film.
"ALL QUIET ON THE WESTERN FRONT"
- Germany
"ARGENTINA, 1985" - Argentina
"CLOSE" - Belgium
"EO" - Poland
And
"THE QUIET GIRL"- Ireland
ALLISON:
Here are the nominees for Best
Animated Feature Film.
ALLISON:
"GUILLERMO DEL TORO'S PINOCCHIO"
"MARCEL THE SHELL WITH SHOES ON"
"PUSS IN BOOTS: THE LAST WISH"
"THE SEA BEAST"
And
"TURNING RED"
RIZ:
Here are the nominees for
Achievement in Makeup and
Hairstyling.
Two groups of artists that we
RIZ:
"ALL QUIET ON THE WESTERN FRONT"
"THE BATMAN"
"BLACK PANTHER: WAKANDA FOREVER"
"ELVIS"
And
"THE WHALE"
Here are the nominees for
Achievement in Production
Design.
RIZ:
"ALL QUIET ON THE WESTERN FRONT"
"AVATAR: THE WAY OF WATER"
"BABYLON"
"ELVIS"
And
"THE FABELMANS"
ALLISON:
The nominees for Achievement in
Film Editing are•
"THE BANSHEES OF INISHERIN"
"ELVIS"
"EVERYTHING EVERYWHERE ALL AT
ONCE"
"TÁR"
And
"TOP GUN: MAVERICK"
RIZ:
Next up, the nominees for
Achievement in Cinematography.
"ALL QUIET ON THE WESTERN FRONT"
"BARDO, FALSE CHRONICLE OF A
HANDFUL OF TRUTHS"
"ELVIS"
"EMPIRE OF LIGHT"
And
"TÁR"
ALLISON:
And now, Achievement in Visual
Effects.
"ALL QUIET ON THE WESTERN FRONT"
"AVATAR: THE WAY OF WATER"
"THE BATMAN"
"BLACK PANTHER: WAKANDA FOREVER"
And
"TOP GUN: MAVERICK"
ALLISON:
It's time for our final 4
awards.
Here are the nominees for
Performance by an Actor in a
Leading Role.
AUSTIN BUTLER in "Elvis"
COLIN FARRELL in "The Banshees
of Inisherin"
BRENDAN FRASER in "The Whale"
PAUL MESCAL in "Aftersun"
And
BILL NIGHY in "Living"
RIZ:
And now the five nominees for
Performance by an Actress in a
Leading Role.
CATE BLANCHETT in "Tár"
ANA de ARMAS in "Blonde"
ANDREA RISEBOROUGH in
"To Leslie"
MICHELLE WILLIAMS in "The
Fabelmans"
And
MICHELLE YEOH in "Everything
Everywhere All at Once"
ALLISON:
Just two categories remain. The
first is Achievement in
Directing.
And the nominees are•
MARTIN McDONAGH
"The Banshees of Inisherin" -
DANIEL KWAN and DANIEL SCHEINERT
"Everything Everywhere All at
Once"
STEVEN SPIELBERG -
"The Fabelmans"
TODD FIELD - "Tár"
And
RUBEN ÖSTLUND - "Triangle of
RIZ:
And now the final category.
Here are the 10 nominees for
Best Motion Picture of the Year.
ALLISON:
"ALL QUIET ON THE WESTERN FRONT"
Malte Grunert, Producer
"AVATAR: THE WAY OF WATER"
James Cameron and Jon Landau,
Producers
"THE BANSHEES OF INISHERIN"
Graham Broadbent, Pete Czernin
and Martin McDonagh, Producers
"ELVIS"
Baz Luhrmann, Catherine Martin,
Gail Berman, Patrick McCormick
and Schuyler Weiss, Producers
"EVERYTHING EVERYWHERE ALL AT
ONCE"
Daniel Kwan, Daniel Scheinert
and Jonathan Wang, Producers
"THE FABELMANS"
Kristie Macosko Krieger
Steven Spielberg and Tony
Kushner, Producers
"TÁR"
Todd Field, Alexandra Milchan
and
Scott Lambert, Producers
"TOP GUN: MAVERICK"
Tom Cruise, Christopher
McQuarrie, David Ellison and
Jerry Bruckheimer, Producers
ALLISON:
"TRIANGLE OF SADNESS"
Erik Hemmendorff and Philippe
Bober,
Producers
RIZ:
And
"WOMEN TALKING"
Dede Gardner, Jeremy Kleiner and
Frances McDormand, Producers
ALLISON:
This was such an honor and huge
congratulations to all the
nominees.
RIZ: Hope ou really soak up this
moment and enjoy everything that
lies ahead of you.
ALLISON:  And in case you didn't
know, Saturday, February 11 is
Global Movie Day. Go see the
nominated movies at your local
theater - tell them we sent you,
and be better prepared for your
Oscar pool!
Tell them we sent you, post
about your favorite movies on
social and get ready for your
Oscar pool!
RIZ:
Thank you for joining us and
congratulations to all the
nominees.  And be sure to watch
the 95th Oscars LIVE with host
Jimmy Kimmel, Sunday March 12th.